halo 2 is one of the most competitive
games in the franchise the player base
broke the boundaries of multiplayer
which skyrocketed the skill ceiling with
glitches that define the title's meta
and are still used by pros to this day
later in halo 2 if you didn't know these
glitches you couldn't compete especially
in ffa for sure because it's all about
speed and timing and then also in fours
if you
dropped a bxr in a clutch situation that
might be four dead for your team and you
lost the game they really molded
halo 2 into kind of a hybrid between a
fighting game and a shooter because
you had to know these very precise
inputs to really keep up with the speed
of the game that's eli the ninja who's a
legendary halo player who made waves in
halo 2 and 3 in the mlg circuit he even
has a call out on midship named after
him and in my opinion he's absolutely
correct despite my fighting game
background i was technically doing my
first tournament combos in halo 2 which
was a little while before i ever played
my first actual fighting game street
fighter 4. funnily enough just as the
earliest street fighter combos were
actually unintentional glitches halo 2's
famous bxr bxb and others came about in
a very similar fashion today we're
checking out those game-changing
glitches as we take a little stroll down
memory lane leave a like subscribe and
let's get into it
we're starting with my favorite the bxr
is where you may like to break an enemy
shields and then glitch the gun to shoot
immediately afterward the names of the
glitches are pretty much how you perform
them so b for beatdown then x and then r
in a quick succession to create the
sense to kill combo the glitch occurs
when you try to reload your gun but
there is nothing to actually reload
whether that be a full clip or your
final one that means you can't do it if
your clip is half full however the game
still reads the reload input which can
then be cancelled into a gunshot despite
the bxr being used mostly with a battle
rifle you can still use this combo with
any weapon in the game a carbine bxr
just hits a little bit different
if you weren't bxr you just were not
going to be at the top i mean
every single pro player could be xr and
vxb
and if you weren't doing those things
your team was not going to succeed
either mastering this technique is not
as daunting as it may sound but can
actually be performed in an alternative
way that is still just as effective if
you swap the x and the r and input brx
you can still get the same desired
effect and instant kills the bxr turned
anyone into a power weapon of their own
and made you feel as if you were
carrying around a shotgun at times i
remember playing online
and walking past the guy
and i just died instantly and i was so
confused i was like what just happened
to me you know i thought he was cheating
at first i said how is it possible that
he just killed me instantly
and it took me a while to figure it out
and then later come to find out he had
bxr'd me and that was like my first
introduction to the bxr was getting
destroyed by this guy who did it
repeatedly another use for the bxr was
the free extra shots you get before the
clip reloads itself the game still reads
the x input and your gun will reload in
about the same time it would have taken
if you perform the animation that's why
you'll often see people starting their
br battles with the bxr no matter the
distance
however most reload glitches won't work
if you have hosts which is basically
when the game chooses you as the server
for the game custom matches usually give
host to the party leader and luckily mcc
has dedicated servers for matchmaking
i mentioned earlier that you'll often
see players use bxr to start their br
fights for extra shots but another
useful reason why it's used is because
you can cancel the tail end of the
reload animation with a beat down for
faster recovery combo that beat down
into an xr and you're now in motion
knowing you can cancel the reload
animation with a beatdown is obviously
going to lead us to the bxb
in the early unpatched version of halo 2
this combo is basically useless because
it took way too many beatdowns to kill
anyone however eventually beatdowns were
fixed and turn into a two hit kill
this turned the bxb into a close range
powerhouse especially if bxr wasn't at
your disposal but unlike the bxr you
could perform the bxb no matter what
your current clip situation is looking
like full half or empty and you could do
it pretty much infinitely if you needed
to
halo 2 classic in mcc can be a little
annoying at times because the beatdowns
don't always register like how they used
to but i suppose we could just chalk
that one up to port problems
excuse me
my melee that's
the double shot and the quad shot is one
of the most difficult techniques in the
game that still have practical value if
you have the execution in my opinion the
good old double shot is where players
really began to stand out from the rest
and showed what it really meant to be
the best at the game and luckily for us
this is one of eli's favorite glitches
because he's one of the best to ever do
it the double shot is a beautiful glitch
so you press rr and x with a battle
rifle normally you just shoot
battle rifle repeatedly so it'd be like
if we're going to use onomatopoeia here
but if you could figure out the double
shot you could essentially shoot a
six bullet burst
instantly so just like
it's just like a double
double shot literally but it was very
high risk and high reward because if you
mess up you're either stuck reloading or
you're stuck in this animation where you
can't really do anything this is
remedied by carrying a secondary weapon
to quickly swap with timing your yy
weapon swap correctly results in a
nearly instant swap back and forth to
your primary weapon which cancels that
reload jam and allows you to perform rrx
again for a quad shot alright it's such
a beautiful glitch and it's it's not
overpowered because if you mess up
you're you're screwed you're gonna die
the grenade reload glitch is definitely
the easiest and most practical glitch in
the game and there's really no drawback
to using it whenever you throw an aid
tap xx in a quick succession during the
throwing animation and voila that's it
if you don't have hosts your gun will
simply reload itself a few seconds later
combining this with the bxr reload and
you can unleash a nearly non-stop
barrage of bullets and catch your
opponents off guard when their clip runs
short
it's such an easy tactic to implement
into your game plan that you'll catch
yourself doing it every time you throw a
name so keep an eye out in case you do
have hosts so you can adjust your
gameplay accordingly and just for
clarity you can't do the glitch if you
don't have any needs
i remember when i learned all these
little combos back in the day and i
can't even picture what halo 2 was like
without them
they become synonymous with my rose
tinted nostalgia for halo 2 multiplayer
the countless hours i spent online and
at lans and became the foundation of how
i looked at competitive gaming
and knowing this skill ceiling existed
heightened my respect for the pros and
made me even more passionate about the
game but to put a pause on all of the
nostalgia for just a moment it's
important to remember that halo infinite
is the beginning of a completely new era
of halo esports eli himself is going to
be the head coach for our g1 officials
very first halo team and will be a part
of defining a meta for a completely new
chapter and it's really awesome to know
that glitches are kind of how eli got
his start in all of this to be honest
with you before i was a competitive
gamer all i was interested in was
glitches and games i mean as a little
kid growing up i was always on those
like websites like
the cheat codes for goldeneye on
nintendo 64 or like little tricks to get
outside the map
so i would say probably the first glitch
i learned in halo
was uh from like reading the online
forums and learning like the super
bounce like the super bounce is
something that
people can't even experience anymore
because they took it out of the current
versions of the game
with that said i want to know what your
favorite glitches so leave a comment
down below and if you enjoyed this video
please leave us a like we'll be covering
even more cool halo things here on
gamespot so subscribe before you go so
you don't miss out thanks so much for
watching and we'll see you next time
peace
[Music]
you